Somewhat orthogonal to unit testing, integration testing, and system testing
is a testing technique called differential testing.
In differential testing what we're doing is taking the same test input,
delivering it to 2 different implementations of the software under test,
and comparing them for equality.
Differential testing is extremely powerful in the case where we have multiple versions.
Stress testing is a kind of testing where a system is tested
at or beyond its normal usage limits, and it's probably best described
through a couple of examples.
For example, with the square root function that we were talking about earlier
we might test it with very large numbers or very tiny numbers.
For an operating system we might test it by making a huge number of system calls
or by making very large memory allocations or by creating
extremely large files.
For a web server we could stress test it by making many requests,
or even better, by making many requests, all of which require
the database to communicate with its back end.
Stress testing is typically done to assess the robustness
and reliability of the software under test.
And finally, we have what might be my favorite kind of testing, random testing.
In random testing we use the results of a pseudo-random number generator
to randomly create test inputs, and we deliver those to the system under test.
And sometimes we're just feeding raw, random bits to the software under test,
but very often this can be much more subtle and more sophisticated
than just throwing random bits at the software.
And random testing is very often useful for finding corner cases
in software systems, and the crashme program for Linux and other Unix kernels
that we talked about earlier is a great example of a random tester,
and we'll talk about more examples later on in this course.